claire baussian pratiquer l'équitation
en amazone depuis dix ans aux écuries du
château de plaisir
cette discipline consiste à chevaucher
avec les jambes du même côté du cheval
la technique a été inventé au xvième
siècle par les femmes de la royauté
c'est une discipline assez ancienne qui
était réservée aux dames
noble nous avons des et des écuyères
amazon très célèbre sissi impératrice
que tout le monde connaît qui y montent
et parfaitement en amazone et qui
pratiquaient toutes les disciplines de
l'amazone donc le dressage tout le monde
a vu six 6 sauter un beau bosquet de
fleurs pour monte en amazone mais
cavalière s'habille généralement avec
une veste cintrée et une jupe longue
le cheval est lui équipé d'une salle
spéciale composée d'un seul étrillé à
gauche et de deux fourches pour enrouler
la jambe
la jambe gauche bien se caler sous la
fourche inférieur par rapport à une
salle classique la selle et flatte le
siège d et bien en arrière et bien plat
une selle qui modifie les sensations en
loisir ou en compétition
la position des mains est primordial en
amazone est plus complexe
il faut vraiment avoir une main fixe
parce que comme on n'a pas de jambes
à droite la badine nom qui est la grande
cravache qu'on a à ma droite qui
remplace note de jambe droite si on a
les maquis bouge on fait peur un autre
cheval est notre cheval ne comprend pas
les ordres qu'on va lui donner
pour tester cette discipline des
baptêmes sont programmées régulièrement
aux écuries du château de plaisir claire
de son côté espère pratiques et
l'amazone pendant encore une dizaine
d'années